Go!!
1,2,3 a song about 'lectricty
because it powers our lives,
makes it possible for us to thrive
Oh, 4, 5, 6, volts of potential difference
makes electrons go round
if the circuit is complete and sound
Circuit's closed
Voltage There
Current Flows
Power Everywhere
We use AC, in factories
and homes because we can transform it
High voltage transmits with lower loss
but low voltage is best for safety
I said what is electricity?
Well, so 1,2,3 a song about 'lectricty
because it powers our lives
makes it possible for us to thrive
Oh, 4, 5, 6, volts of potential difference
makes electrons go round
if the circuit is complete and sound
Heat makes steam
turns turbines and a
magnet in
coils of wires
We use AC in factories
and homes because we can transform it
High voltage transmits with lower loss
but low voltage is best for safety
I said what is electricity?
Oh yeah,
C'mon!
How'd it be
no energy
of the electrical persuasion
I know we'd have no computers
no internet or mobile phones yeah
Powers the world
Makes the world
We need electricity yeah